إيقاع وقت
الأب ، قرع شوارع
المدينة ، مشهد صوت براغ ينبض بالحياة
[موسيقى]
فلا عجب أن هناك مقولة قديمة هنا
كل
شيك موسيقي
[موسيقى]
أجنبية ،
نعم نحن في أجمل
مسرح في  العالم في مسرح العقارات
في براغ ،
أود أن أقول إنه أحد
جواهر الأوبرا التاريخية ، كان هنا أن
قدم فولفغانغ أماديوس
موزارت أوبراه دون
جيوفاني التي
تعتبر واحدة من أرقى الأوبرا التي تم تأليفها على الإطلاق بعد
200 عام في نفس
المسرح ، عازفون منفردون كاتارينا و
أدم آدم أدوارًا في دون جيوفاني ،
هذا هو المنزل الوحيد في العالم الذي
لا يزال يلعب الأوبرا حيث
أجرى موزارت ليلتين من ليالي افتتاحه
ووقف هنا موزارت وقف هنا ما كان
يفعله وكان يلعب دور تيمبالا
بنفسه في نفس الوقت
قال موزارت المذهل  أفهمني
برايجر وأعتقد أنه كان لا بد من
[الموسيقى] أن
تفعل مع حقيقة أنه هنا كان
النجم الكامل والأول
ما هذا عن هذا  مكان تشعر فيه
بالسحر في هذا
المجال بالتأكيد ، هل تشعر بذلك بالتأكيد ، هل تشعر
بأداء مختلف على هذه المرحلة ، نعم ، الأمر
مختلف قليلاً
لأنني أحب المسرح الذي أشعر به في المنزل
هنا وحبي ،
حيث قابلت في
المعهد الموسيقي في براغ
[موسيقى]
بعد سنوات ، ازدهر الحب بين
مغني الأوبرا
هذين على
المسرح وخارجه ، أشعر بالأمان مع آدم على المسرح ،
أشعر براحة شديدة ،
فقط طرفة عين اليسرى
وأعرف
ما يريد أن
يغفر لي في نفس المكان
الذي يوجد فيه موزارت  أجرى دون جيوفاني
في قاعة الأوبرا حيث تم تقديمه لأول
مرة من يمكنه مقاومة
[موسيقى] ،
من أطفأ
الأنوار لم أنته لم يكن بهذا السوء